FALSE.
>> Tucker: FRESHMAN
PHILOSOPHY CLASS.
YOU’RE EXACTLY RIGHT THOUGH.
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: STEVEN COHEN IS
PROFESSOR EMERITUS OF
RUSSIAN STUDIES AND POLITICS
AT NYU AND PRINCETON, A
CONTRIBUTING EDITOR OF THE
NATION MAYBE THE MOST FAMOUS
RUSSIAN SCHOLAR IN THE
UNITED STATES.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
PROFESSOR, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
SO, AM I MISSING -- I JUST
WANT TO BE ABSOLUTELY CLEAR
BECAUSE I THINK THIS HELPS
INFORM HOW WE SEE THIS
INVESTIGATION.
ARE YOU AWARE OF ANY OTHER
EVIDENCE AT ALL OF COLLUSION
BETWEEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AND RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT OTHER
THAN THE DOSSIER?
>> NO.
NONE.
BUT, THERE ARE TWO DOCUMENTS
THAT BECAME THE FOUNDATIONAL
SOURCES FOR THE KREMLIN GATE
NARRATIVE.
IT WAS FIRST THE STEELE
DOSSIER WHICH SURELY
INFORMED THE SO-CALLED
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
ASSESSMENT IN JANUARY OF
2017.
WE WERE TOLD THAT WAS THE
JUDGEMENT OF 17 INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES.
IT NOW TURNS OUT TO HAVE
BEEN THE JUDGMENT OF NO
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY.
JUST A FEW GUYS AT THE TOP.
THAT’S ALL THAT’S EVER BEEN
PRODUCED AND IT’S NOT
CREDIBLE.
>> Tucker: WHAT ABOUT, WE
NOVEMBER THAT DOSSIER WAS AT
LEAST PART OF THE RATIONALE
FEW OF THE WARRANT THAT
ALLOWED THE FEDS TO SPY ON
CARTER PAGE.
DO YOU THINK OTHER PEOPLE IN
TRUMP’S ORBIT DURING THE
CAMPAIGN WERE SPIED ON BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
>> OH, I DON’T KNOW.
THE ARTICLE I JUST PUBLISHED
IN THE NATION I ASKED THAT
QUESTION.
WE NEED TO FIND OUT.
I MEAN WHY DID THEY, FOR
EXAMPLE, GET A WARRANT ON
CARTER PAGE, WHO ON THE VERY
SURFACE OF IT, IS NO THREAT
TO AMERICAN NATIONAL
SECURITY.
AND THEN ON PAUL MANAFORT.
WE MIGHT ASSUME THEY DID IT
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT THESE
TWO MEN WOULD BE CLOSE, EVEN
IN THE SAME ROOM WITH DONALD
TRUMP.
AND WANTED TO SURVEIL HIM.
BUT, LET ME JUST MAKE ONE
POINT, CARTER -- TUCKER.
WHAT INTERESTS ME IS NOT WHO
PAID FOR THE DOSSIER.
WE KNOW IT WAS THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> BUT WHERE STEELE GOT THIS
INFORMATION.
IN THE ARTICLE I WRITE, I
SUGGEST THAT IT’S HIGHLY
UNLIKELY HE GOT IT FROM HIS
SO-CALLED CONNECTIONS IN THE
KREMLIN.
NOW, THERE’S A TEMPT
UNDERWAY TO REHABILITATE
STEELE.
ON THE FRONT PAGE OF "THE
WASHINGTON POST" TODAY THERE
IS A STORY THAT PORTRAYS HIM
AS A CHARACTER OF THE SPY.
HE MAY WELL BE.
A MAN PURPOSE IN LIFE.
WE TIRED EARLY AGE AND FOR
HIRE.
THIS IS THE GUY WHO NOW
ENTERS OUR LIFE AND USED AND
LARGER QUESTION THAT COMES
TO MY MIND BUT YOU KNOW THE
ANSWER BETTER THAN I DO IS
HOW MANY BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT DO WE ACTUALLY
HAVE?
I WAS TAUGHT WE HAD THREE.
WHAT’S BEEN GOING ON ABOVE,
WITH THE INTELLIGENCE
SERVICES AND NOT ONLY THE
FBI, RAISES THE QUESTION IS
THERE IS A FOURTH BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT THAT’S INFLUENCES
NOT ONLY OUR POLITICIANS BUT
BECAUSE THEY WERE LEAKING TO
THE MEDIA, WHAT WE VOTERS
THINK WHEN WE GO TO VOTE.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK THAT
THE INFORMATION IN THE
DOSSIER AND YOU ARE A
CREDIBLE PERSON TO ASK THIS
OF.
DO YOU THINK IT’S CREDIBLE?
I MEAN, DO YOU THINK IT’S
REAL?
DO YOU THINK IT CAME FROM